hi everyone welcome to the rmk lectures
a distinguished lecture I'm Chevy Volt
master and this is the lecture series
that we are extremely proud of it's in
honor of the cards achievements
contributions to a computer science and
computer science and it was established
due to a very generous gift by many
people in honor of dick he's celebrating
everything is done for computer science
and we are especially fortunate today to
have the nearly muchacho from UC San
Diego and the neela is a leader that the
leader of the research on the lattices
and the applications cryptography going
back many years Act I'm very proud to
say the Nina was a student of mine and
MIT many many years ago and he has done
fundamental work on showing the hardness
of certain lattice problems on designing
crypto systems designing encryption
systems a lot of innovations that are
used throughout throughout any system
that actually doesn't want more for
encryption today and today he's gone and
he's also gifted speaker lucky toss for
us and he's going to speak on lattices
post quantum security and fully
homomorphic encryption and Daniela is a
visitor in this program and it semester
in fact he was about to fly from San
Diego he was on his way to the airport
when they declared that there's gonna be
a shelter at home so he stayed in San
Diego welcome to LA thank you very much
for giving the first remote rmk lecture
fully remote arm came it annually
okay thank you for the introduction
thank you for the invitation I'm happy
to be there virtually at least and so
I'll be talking about lattices post
quantum security and a fully homomorphic
encryption so encryption is that main
main topic and encryption is the classic
problem is the tool used by cryptography
to solve the classic problem secure
communication over an insecure Channel
so if two people Allison
Bob did want to exchange a message in in
secrecy and there's an evil dropper that
is intercept in their communication so
Alice and Bob can still achieve secrecy
if they share a secret key or a pair of
public and secret keys that are used by
Alice to encrypt that message under the
public key computing a cipher text which
is sent to Bob and Bob can use that
match in a secret key to decrypt the
ciphertext and recover the original
message in this case just hi and Eve
anniversa that does not have access to
the secret the decryption key will not
be able to get any information on that
messenger now modern cryptography rests
on a solid the mathematical foundation
and the approach used in cryptography to
build the secure solution to
communication problems
another problem set is to start from
hard mathematical problems and the
classic problem used by many key to
graphic functions this day is these days
is the factoring problem the problem of
factoring a large number say the product
of two primes P and Q so given the
product P times Q you want to find P and
Q and is a problem that is considered to
be hard at least in the classical
setting now using the mathematical
problem and this harness you want to
exploit this harness to build a
cryptographic scheme that achieves some
security goal for example encryption and
the approach of modern cryptography is
to exploit this harness to build the
cryptographic functions that achieve
their intended the security security
goal in a probable way so showing that
if you can brew if you were able to
break the encryption scheme then you
would be able to solve the corresponding
hard a mathematical problem in this case
factoring numbers and if you just take
the logically equivalent contrapositive
of this implication if you assume that
factoring is hard
then you can rest assured that
encryption scheme is secure there is no
way to break it unless some big
breakthrough in mathematics occurs now
all of these specifically for factoring
changed the Sun 25 years ago when Peter
shor came up with an efficient quantum
algorithm that can factor numbers now
this algorithm couldn't be run at a time
he still cannot be run today because we
don't have that quantum computers or at
least the quantum computers that are big
enough to run that algorithm but the
fact that it is theoretically possible
to use quantum physics to build
computers that are able to solve the
factoring problem pretty much puts this
factoring problem out of business for
cryptography it means that the
assumption that factoring high is hard
does not hold in a post quantum world a
world where large-scale quantum
computers have been built and the same
also for many other cryptographic
schemes that have been used in the past
and are still used to these days
including schemes based on the discrete
logarithm problem infinite fields or
elliptic curves and so this calls for
new mathematical problems mathematical
problems that are hard even assuming
that quantum computers have been built
and can be used to run short algorithm
or other algorithms to attack them so
Lucky's problems is Latisse problems are
a class of problems that seem to fit the
bill at least as far as we know and but
before we're talking about Lucky's
problems and lattices let me first
introduce the problem using a subset sum
now subsystem is a classic a simple
problem that involves only the addition
operation so you are given a set of
integer numbers say 1 in 2 up to a n
also a target value B and the question
that you have to answer is is there a
subset of these numbers a 1 to a n which
if added up give you precisely B as a
result now these the classic a subset
sum problem and these numbers are often
called weights of the subset sum then
they are just integer numbers and this
problem is there are several variants of
these problems and some of them are
called a knapsack problem that's an
alternative name for the same or very
similar problem and in this setting the
problem is defined in analogy with the
problem of packing a knapsack you have a
knapsack of a certain capacity being the
size of the knapsack or the maximum
weight that you can carry with it and
then you also have a collection of items
of different size or weight and the
question is if you can fill the knapsack
up to capacity using a selection of
those B items so you can make optimal
use of the capacity asking didn't IBM
manage to factor 15 the number 15 using
Shor's oh yes I can also do that it is 3
times 5 and so I think that it's very
interesting that you can build proof of
concept show in a debt in principle that
the algorithm is workable we just don't
have the computers that are big enough
to run it on numbers that are large
enough to be interesting by cryptography
now if you are using 15 as or RSA
modulus well you don't need the quantum
computers to be hacked and I can do that
the more cheaply I will charge less than
IBM if you want to factor numbers of
that size ok so I don't have the chart
open
and so if anything comes up I mean yeah
so I can't on the Q&A open I can will
seen some chat to Q&A
oh I don't have anything open I can try
to open it I need to find a way so let's
say QA I could just read it I mean
should we do we know that if I open the
window then it resizes the slides and
then might cause problems so we anyway
I'll go over all the line all the
questions at the end okay so let's move
on so these the knapsack problem and so
there are different variants sometime
you consider variants where the items
can be used multiple times not just as
upset about a multi set of diamond and
well this problem seems deceivingly
simple it only involves admission a much
simpler operation than multiplication
but well if you think it is easy then I
invite you to try it out the next time
you go to your favorite restaurant and
you can see if you can get your desired
order and of course once this you know
pandemic is over and we can all go back
okay so the problem is hard in fact it
is np-complete and it is not just an
np-complete problem it is one of the
problems from the original list of 21 MP
complete problems started by carp back
in 1972 so this is a landmark paper that
established that field of NP
completeness by showing that a large
number of problems of interest in
computer science are all equivalent
under polynomial time reductions so we
can say that in the knapsack problem or
the subset-sum problem has been a known
to be np-complete the pretty much since
people have known about NP completeness
at all so it's a classic problem and
have been empty complete it seems a very
good candidate as
problem that cannot be solved
efficiently you know your time either
using classic or quantum computers so
understand or assumptions like P is
different from MP or MP is not contained
in the QP we know we don't we don't we
do not expect any algorithm to solve
this problem efficiently so lattice
cryptography so it is something that has
been is closely related to using the
knapsack for cryptography I'll show in a
moment what the lattice is what's the
relation between lattices and a subset
sum so it's not surprising that people
have been tried I've been trying to use
the subset sum problem or the knapsack
problem to build the cryptography and in
fact the first of times to do so started
in already in the seventies in the late
seventies when Merkel in helmand had
proposed a knapsack base the public key
cryptosystem however the system had got
broken by Shamir and ligarius in at
least co and incidentally they used the
lattices to carry out the attack and
still it seemed like a good idea and
many variants of the knapsack problem
used the for cryptography kept that
being suggested or almost two decades
but they were always broken one after
the other and perhaps all these say all
these attempts and designs proposals and
failures of the knapsack base the
cryptography our best epitomized by the
title of the paper of at least so-called
the rise and fall of the knapsack of
knapsack cryptosystem which pretty much
shows how people felt about it in the
early nineties now all of this changed
in the mid nineties when I I reached a
turning point showing that there is a
very interesting connection between the
worst case in average case complexity
latias problems closely related to the
nap suckin subset-sum problem and in
some sense we can think of this result
as showing the right way the correct way
to use knapsack and lattis problems to
build the cryptographic functions so as
people were about to completely give up
at using lattices and subset-sum for
cryptography we found a good way to
chart which is I guess relevant to these
last two slides from failing saying D
way we can do any three-digit number
this is a factory but it's not used sure
I'll quiz my reverse multiplication
circuit and it's building serious
applications for the city waiter
I mean just oh ok so that's very so
maybe that's something that could at the
end could be discussed unless we will
have to finish 12 I mean is 12 because
there's another talk on the same on the
same line I think so yeah so I'll be
happy to discuss this offline or in some
other follow-up meeting so I'll be there
eventually the Simon's Institute for the
next several weeks so you know where to
find me ok so moving on so what is a
lattice and how does it relate to some
now the typical let's a lattice problem
is just a variant of the subset-sum
problem where instead of adding up
integer numbers you adopt vectors so it
doesn't it is something that is very
very similar you can still describe it
as a subset sum problem but it is a
subset sum over a different type of
object an N dimensional vector now you
can also so this vectors are added up
using the standard vector addition
operation component wise and you can
consider standard such as some problems
over vectors all right you can also
consider variants where you take notice
of
setback an integer combination of the
input vectors with small coefficients
you can even use negative coefficients
as you like but the key feature is that
the coefficients should be small so in
some sense lattice problems and subsets
some problems are the same type of
problems is just that lattices with
their n dimensional structure are often
more convenient to use in the design of
the cryptographic applications so just
to show you what a lot is look like you
have a collection of the basis vectors
in two dimension you can only draw two
dimensional lattices so you are given
two vectors V 1 and V 2 and you take the
set of all the integer combinations of
these two vectors V 1 and V 2 which
produce the set of intersection point of
an n-dimensional grid now so this
provides a nice geometric intuition of
what a lattice is this is often very
useful when design in a cryptographic
algorithms cryptographic when designing
algorithms to solve lattice problems
however in the design of cryptographic
functions this is not that critical it
is possible to just use a standard
matrix formulation without pictures and
I will not be using these geometric
visualization of lattices in the rest of
the talk so that is in the construction
of cryptographic functions will be
something more closely related to the
matrix a formulation of linear algebra
you can take the weights of your
knapsack problem a 1 a 2 and so on so
these are vectors you can put them one
next to the other forming and matrix a
now selecting a subset of these vectors
or a small linear combination of these
vectors is exactly a problem of matrix
vector multiplication you have a matrix
a and you multiply it by a vector X so
it's a linear function and make the
knapsack problem and even the output of
this function be asked to and even also
a
describes the function as to find a
input X which produces the correct
output and one important feature of this
function is that it is linear so it's
the simplest type of is not the simplest
simplest function would be the constant
one but it's one of the simplest type of
functions you can think of them and the
technique you can give the cryptography
out of it is quite surprising and but
more than that there so this linearity
property which at first was considered a
potential weakness and a reason to be
concerned about a use of knapsack in
cryptography these also can be the key
to some of the attacks two subsets and
based hash functions so this also turns
out to be useful and as we will see
lattices with their linearity property
can be used to do some amazing things
not just do the same cryptographic
functions which are secured against
potential quantum attacks but also to
build a very powerful cryptographic
primitives now notice in if you just
describe these as a linear function is
so so this is not a this is not a hard
problem computing the function is a
matrix matrix vector multiplication and
you can also easily invert a function
you can easily find a solution X to the
system ax equals B you can do it using
Gaussian elimination or your favorite
method to solve the linear systems so
the problem becomes hard when you
restrict the input to be a short vector
for example is zero one vector if you
want a subset some of the columns of the
matrix a now if you restrict the input
to such a subset which is a nonlinear is
a nonlinear subset of the input space
then you have the problem of finding a
small solution to a system of linear
equations which cannot be solved using
in elimination or any other non
efficient technique so this provides a
one-way function a function which is
still easy to compute given a and X you
can easily compute B which is the
product a times X and but it is hard to
invert where inversion requires to find
a small input X which is 0-1 or more
generally bounded by some parameter beta
that describes how small should vector X
to be considered a valid solution to
this problem now in many cryptographic
applications there is a slightly
different formulation which is often
used and that's called the learning with
errors problem the two problems is in
tactically can be related one to the
other using lattice duality but I will
not talk about that but since this is
the formulation we will use in the rest
of the talk let me briefly describe it
so in the learning with our problem
you're given a matrix a this time it is
a matrix which as typically full column
rank so it has longer columns so that
eight of the column M is bigger than the
number of columns and so if I were to
give you a times s then even if s is
smaller you could easily find it using
Gaussian elimination just because the
solution is typically unique so a times
X is an injective function so in order
to make the problem hard to solve we add
an error component e to the product a
times X and the learning with our
problem asks given a and B computed this
way can you find a secret as a short
vector or even a long one long vector s
such that a s plus E is equal to B so s
here can be arbitrary but e the error
should be small now even if you add this
error this function is still injective
and that what makes the learning with
our problem much
more useful to build applications then
the subset-sum problem I described
before and you can think of these as an
injective version of I ties short
integer solution problem function and so
this problem was in this formulation was
proposed and proved by Ragan in 2005
showing that under a similar assumptions
as those made by tie this problem is
still hard and assuming that lattice
prints are hard even for quantum
computers interestingly rag of original
reduction used the power of quantum
computing to transform one problem into
another so it was a quantum reduction
that produces the quantum algorithms
even if I were to give you a classic
algorithms to solve
lwe the learning with our problem now
and not only the problem is hard to
solve in its search version it is hard
to invert dysfunctional recover s-rank
it also showed that the output of this
function this vector B is a pseudo
random it is computationally
indistinguishable from a uniform vector
in the range of that function so an
n-dimensional vector with entries modulo
Q so this Q is just a small integer
modulus which is used so that this
lattice problem it can be formulated as
a problem a very finite group and Q is
not a hard to factor number doesn't have
to have any specific structure and the
source of harness in this problem is the
fact that these matrices have a
non-trivial size so you have matrix with
n columns and M rows and as you increase
the number of columns for example
performing an exhaustive search over all
possible secret vectors s becomes not
feasible
now this harness result of reggae was
later improved by bikers in 2009 and by
brickowski at all in 2013 so in an
almost equivalent classical version of
reggae reduction so we have we are
confident that this problem is hard and
we also had a good way to use it in
cryptography and how it is used in
cryptography so what I'll describe now
is how to build a very simple object
which is a private key encryption scheme
so we use the fact that the output to be
of the learning with our problem is
pseudo-random so it will look random to
any adversary that does not have the
secret key s so we think of s has been
the secret encryption or decryption key
so here I'm talking about the private
key encryption not publicly one is about
the sender and receiver use the same key
s and since B is a value which will look
random to anybody else you can use it to
build an encryption scheme using it
essentially as a one-time pad you can
use it to mask your message m by adding
B to B and so this will look random to
the adversary and hide any partial
information about your messages so the
message consists of an lwe output which
is a B to which you have added the M or
if you want you can think of it as
having the LW e pair a B to which you
add the matrix 0 m which can be
interpreted as an Inc as an insecure
encryption of m is a ciphertext of n
that does not really hide using m in two
places here yeah sorry
you mean the green message yeah I mean
the green one yeah by the
how to change the color of the pen you
can ignore these yeah busy index yes
also these are different things so that
this is the message and Here I am adding
yes the message and you talking about
vector addition here yes it is vector
addition and yeah but here M is actually
just seeing a source of B in this
setting is just an integer so there is
no M here it is actually an integer in
this specific example you can extend the
disc in easily using bigger matrices so
you can encrypt the vector at a time but
yeah so in this case and even the
message m is just any integer but it is
a different integer than the number of
rows of course sorry for the confusion
okay so similar encryption schemes where
I proposed the using a problem called
the learn imperative windows which is
essentially the same as lwe but using
add modulus equal to two you're
performing addition of beats and the
length of vectors is measured in the
Hamming in the Hamming distance and so
these had already been proposed back in
the early nineties and so these paper
actually proposed the h2 the random
generator and a stream cipher if you
know what it is using the problem and a
description of a block cipher so the
random function or encryption scheme
using this type of this type of problem
was explicitly described by Gilbert at
all in 2009 so regular w/e essentially
is a generalization of this problem with
larger modulus where Q instead of being
2 is a polynomial in the dimension n of
the matrix okay so let's look at the
decryption algorithm and you can decrypt
your reciter texts in a pretty easy way
what you do is given a and B and B also
is this message and the component added
to it you take the second component and
you subtract from you
eight times s now using the definition
of B you can just carry out this
operation and see that as a result you
get exactly M plus this non error that
was added to their lwe instance to make
it hard to break so you see that from
this algorithm what you did is not the
message m but an aperture version of
that messenger so in some sense it is a
noisy decryption algorithm which does
not recover the message exactly it gives
a corrupted version of the message but
this problem is easily solved by using
some form of error correction so for
example you could reduce the message
space to consist of only the multiples
of say Q over forever q is the modulus
so this is a discrete set where
different messages are at distance Q
over for one from the other
now if the error which is added to a
message is less than Q over 8 then all
these orange regions consisting of a
tortured match century will be disjoint
and you can recover the exact value of
the message exactly die rounding it to
the closest multiple of the Q over four
so we will not be a concern about these
error in the rest of the top so it plays
an important role in the design analysis
of applications you have to be very
careful about it in the application so
that the error can be corrected but
there is a standard way to do it now so
this is the basic encryption scheme how
to use lwe for encryption but I want to
do more than that
so the reason lattices became so popular
these days is not just because they
offer a potential solution to encryption
in a post quantum world but there are
also many interesting powerful
applications that build on lattices now
specifically you can build the
encryption scheme which supports the
computation on encrypted data now
standard encryption schemes
allowed to encrypt your data store it in
a secure way then retrieve it or
transmit it but that's all you can do
now in a fully homomorphic encryption
scheme you can encrypt your message keep
it to an untrusted server and the
untrusted said that can compute on it so
if you give a program F to this server
the server can run the program on the
encrypted data without the grid unit
without even knowing the decryption key
and it will come up with an encrypted
version of the result of the problem now
this opens up the door to many
interesting applications of encryption
where encryption is used in a more
dynamic way now fully homomorphic
encryption is a classic problem in
cryptography it was the concept that was
originally proposed back in the late 70s
by reversed other Menander to those back
back then it was just an open problem
nobody knew how to solve the problem it
was not until recently that first the
candidate the solution to the problem
god was found in 2009 a Craig trench we
found a first candidate solution and
more importantly he introduced the
abstracting technique that proved to be
critical in all the subsequent
constructions now there's been a much
much work after that
providing efficiency improvements better
security guarantees implementations and
libraries that I will not be able to
talk about what I want to do in the rest
of the talk is to give an idea of how
all of these works and how you go from
just addition which is a very simple
operation to not just a secure
encryption scheme by an encryption
scheme that supports arbitrary
computations so I will do this in a
mostly informal way omitting many
technical details about trying to convey
the main ideas behind many of the known
constructions now it shouldn't be much
of a surprise that the lattice based
encryption
supports home
morphic a vision that is given to
ciphertexts you can add them up and the
sum of two cipher texts if you just do
your algebra you'll see it is the
encryption of the sum of the two
messages so you have here two
expressions representing the encryption
of m1 and m2 and if you are the map just
as matrices so these are simple matrix
addition operation so if you do that you
can factor out these the secret s and
express it as the sum of a 1 and a 2
multiplied by s similarly you can group
together the 2 error terms and you can
group together the two messages so if
you use this notation encryption of M
with noise it most better as a way to
represent all the cipher texts encrypt
in a certain message with a bounded
amount of noise then you can see that
the sum of the encryption of m1 with the
encryption of M 2 is an encryption of M
plus 2 with a noise which is the son of
the noises of the two original cipher
texts and similarly you can also
multiply your ciphertext by a constant C
and as you perform this product and is
just a scalar matrix the product is a
very simple operation if you look at the
definition you will see that the message
is being multiplied by C and also the
error is being multiplied by C so this
means that you can also multiply a
ciphertext by a constant but you can
only do so if the constant C is small if
C is large then the error gets
multiplied by a large number it will
become too big and then you will not be
able to decrypt so so up this up to this
part we have a method to take linear
combinations of cipher texts with small
coefficients so there are linear
combination of small coefficients now we
would like to do more than that and a
first simple thing that can be done is
the multiply ciphertext by arbitrary
possibly large constants and this can be
done by defining n
hence the encryption scheme here I'm
writing and calling it encryption Prime
and so in these enhanced encryption
scheme you encrypt and not just a
message m by also encrypt using the
original scheme multiples of m and you
don't need to consider many of them you
just take multiples that are equal to M
times a power of 2 and so with
logarithmic Alemany cipher texts you get
a ciphertext of the new scheme and now
you can multiply them by any constant C
simply by writing C in binary and once
it's constant C has been written in
binary you can express the
multiplication by C is a subset sum of
those messages so you can take a subset
sum where you select the cipher texts
that have binary digit in the constants
C equal to 1 since the scheme supports
the computation of linear functions
homomorphic Ali you can take the
summation inside the dank region and you
can factor out the end and you can
recover the cost and see inside the
ciphertext so now we have a scheme that
allowed to compute arbitrary linear
functions you can multiply your
ciphertext by any constant and now
notice the result is so you're starting
from this enhanced encryption scheme B
Prime and the result is a different
encryption scheme but it is easy to
extend the scheme to produce results
according to the original encryption
scheme B Prime
simply by not applying your tiefer
ciphertext not just by C but you can
also multiplied by 2 C 4 C 8 C and so on
so if you do this then you will get the
result according to the same encryption
scheme as you started with so so there
is a standard way to convert to use this
linearity property also to achieve the
public key encryption but just in the
interest of time since we need to finish
early let me skip that and
me move let's move it to a different
operation which is multiplication
now addition is not much of a surprise
that is supported by lapis based
encryption because it is a linear
problem is it possible to multiply
ciphertext is there a way given an
encryption of m1 an encouragement to to
obtain the encryption of the product n1
times n2 with the noise that is possibly
a function of the noise of the original
cycle texts now this operation seems to
go beyond what you would reasonably
expect from lattices and subsets Sun but
surprisingly this can be done now there
is a nicer presence because if you can
do multiplication then you can perform
arbitrary computations so if you
represent your bits as zeros and ones
then all the operations all the binary
operations like negation a logical and
logical order can all be expressed as
combination of the linear functions so
for example 1 minus AXA correspond to
logical negation multiplication gives
exactly addition it gives exactly the
logical end of 2 bits and you can also
express that logical order of 2 bits if
you also have at your disposal at
multiplication operation so being able
to do both addition and multiplication
is the key to do anything you want to
perform arbitrary computations so so how
can you multiply ciphertext now it is
quite surprising that the linearity
property of sub the cement lattices
allows to do that and in fact it allows
to do that in several different ways
there are different ways to exploit
linearity to achieve multiplication and
you can do it by nest in encryption
functions using the tensor products of
ciphertext so you can use it you can do
that using the linear properties of the
decryption or you can even do it by
combining some of the bootstrapping
technique which is needed to perform
arbitrary computations ok
there with a computationally simple
binary case now different methods that
are used to multiply ciphertext so
that's the main difference between
different lattice based encryption
schemes so all that is based encryption
schemes by enlarge we used the same
encryption function at the same
decryption the same method to add the
cipher texts sometime they use different
coatings of the messages but to a large
extent they are essentially the same
encryption scheme so the main difference
in between different schemes is how
multiplication is performed and I want
to quickly review these four methods so
to perform a multiplication and just in
a couple of minutes to give an idea of
the variety of techniques that can be
used to build a home Orphic encryption
now let's start with encryption by
nesting now so you are given two
ciphertext C 0 and C 1 which encrypt
messages m0 and m1 under a scheme that
is linearly how morphic so how can you
multiply this to a ciphertext well you
can multiply c0 homomorphic elite by c1
so at this point you my object that oh
well that's what you want to do this
they go what do you mean you don't know
how to do that well you want to multiply
c0 homomorphic ali using c1 as a linear
transformation think of c1 has been a
constant since this is 0 is a linearly
horf exciter text you can multiply it by
a constant value c1 now if you do so you
can bring the DS the c1 inside
the encryption scheme that protects and
0 and get an encryption of m0 times that
cost and the c1 the MA times c1 the
value that is encrypted under is 0 again
by the linearity of the encryption
scheme used it to build c1 is an
encryption and possibly different key
om1 which is multiplied by n 0 so you
can take this n 0 and bring it inside
these encryption computation so if you
combine these two that
so together you see that the final
result is the encryption of the product
and zero times m1 which is encrypted
under two schemes first under s1 and
then under s0 so it is a nested
encryption which can be decrypted if you
know the two keys you just first peel
off the first layer of encryption and
then you peel off the second layer now
interestingly since that both functions
are linear also their composition is
linear so the resulting scheme still
supports additional so after you've done
this multiplication you can perform
additions of cipher texts so and the
approach extends also to multiplying
longer sequences of messages in cipher
text so you can multiply 3 4 5 any as
many as you want now there are many
details that are technically very
critical which I omitted so for example
the fact that you can only multiply on
the left not on the right and this
ciphertext as the you nest encryptions
get bigger and bigger and this is the
basic idea behind this multiplication
method which was proposed by aguilar at
all back in 2010 Creek actually based on
a paper that so a preliminary version of
the work already existing 2008 even
before a Craig train three bootstrap in
a breakthrough now this is an interest
in a simple approach to perform
multiplication but it is very limited in
terms of what you can do I said this
ciphertext get bigger a big get bigger
and bigger you can only perform a very
small number of multiplications so in
fact even using an improved version of
this scheme which is from 2011 you I
think you can only perform at most a sub
linear number of multiplication and in
the paper it is made clear that the
scheme does not support bootstrapping so
you can perform addition and
multiplication you can use it to
evaluate low degree polynomial that
that's where it stops now let's
look a different method to do
multiplication so this one is called the
multiplication by a tensor in now let me
start with the trivial met order to
perform a multiplication now you can do
the multiplication symbolically if I
give you two ciphertext m0 and m1 and I
tell you all multiply them together you
can just concatenate them and then
append a symbol that says oh I want the
product of them now how do you decrypt
it you decrypt this two component
ciphertext individually and then you
perform the multiplication on the result
of decryption
now of course it is not interesting and
it applies to every operation is very
powerful but it's not really giving you
anything useful and the reason is that
the size of the ciphertext grows with
the computation in fact it will be
linear in the computation size so most
definitions of how much encryption rule
out to this type of solution as a
trillion by requiring that decryption
should be sub linear at least in the
size of the computation was performed on
the ciphertext
now why is this useful so how can we go
from these to something useful well this
trio multiplication method is way more
than what you need now if I give you
both c0 and c1 if I give you two
ciphertext then you can compute any
function of them given this trigonal
multiplication but in practice that's
not what you need these things are
necessary you just want to decrypt the
final ciphertext you don't want to
compute arbitrary functions of the
ciphertext so what you want is a
combination of c1 and c2 a c0 and c1
that supports the computation of the
decryption function so what does this
decryption function look like so if you
go back to the definition you will see
that the decryption function is linear
now so if you decrypt it to cipher texts
and then multiply the result of
decryption together then you will get a
function which is be linear in the
ciphertext C 0 and C 1 so this suggests
that instead of using the concatenation
of C 0 and C 1
can take their tensor product which by
definition of course the computation of
any linear function now this computation
is more efficient than the trivial one
in particular after you've computed this
tensor products you can still add them
up together wrap and support amorphic
addition and there are several
optimizations that are possible using
the fact that you don't even need to
compute arbitrary be linear functions
you just want to compute the be linear
functions corresponding to decryption so
this is the second the multiplication
method and since we don't have much time
left I will skip so so these basically
based on the work of brackets came back
on tonight and which also introduced
method to change the key under which
cipher texts are encrypted and that can
be used to keep the size of the cipher
texts bounded which is useful to perform
arbitrary computations and may support a
larger number of operations so let me
move it to the next so I'll skip the Kin
switching and let me move to the third
method which is multiplication by how a
morphic decryption so in this setting so
you use the fact that the decryption is
linear right not only in the ciphertext
but it is also linear in the secret key
so if instead of using the secret key I
give you a multiple of the secret key
then when you decrypt using this scale
the secret you will get a scale version
of the message so by using different
secret keys you can multiply the message
now so the fact that you can use these
alternative scale the secret Keys
provide a method to perform a
multiplication of cipher texts the idea
is to consider these secret keys that
have been multiplied by C as an
encryption of C
we can perform a decrypt and multiply
operation where when you perform your
normally when if instead of giving the
secret key I give you an encryption of
the secret key when you multiple when
you perform a decryption on an encrypted
secret key you will go back the
encryption of your starting message but
if instead of using the secret key
encrypted you use the encryption of a
multiple of the secret key when you
compute to this amorphic decree
decryption you will get an encryption of
a scale message where the message has
been multiplied by C so you can think of
this as an encryption of C and use that
as a method to perform multiplication so
just want to remind you there five
minutes left
yeah yeah so yes I'm unless let me move
ourselves so I hope these are gives a
little bit of a flavor yeah yeah can we
just move the other talk five minutes
it's just it's not the talk is from
another department okay let me let's not
waste time I'll go on and we can yeah so
we'll yeah so I am almost almost there
right so so this scheme is the same
outright that I just described is
somehow related to the encryption scheme
of Gentry's our high-end waters now that
schema is described in their work at a
different intuition the intuition was
that all cipher texts have approximate
the eigenvectors and again values
so when you multiply a ciphertext by s
you will get basically key you will get
a multiple of s where the these
approximate again value is that message
B that is encrypted by C and so these
are provides I met order to do a
multiplication because if you multiply
two ciphertext together when you
multiplied by s you will get first s
times m2 and then the result will be
multiplied by my
so you see that s is an eigenvector
approximate event vector of the product
to c1 times c2 but we then again baby
which is the product of the two original
eigenvalues now this seems very
different from what I described before
in fact the intuition is very different
the conceptually these are two different
schemes but if you look down at the
operations which are performed at the
very bottom level they are the same
operation so in some sense so these are
technically equivalent encryption
schemes so let me briefly describe it is
only one slide one last met order to
perform a multiplication which I call
the gate boostrap in the idea is that
so this bootstrapping operation which is
needed to perform an arbitrary
computations on ciphertext can also be
used to get for free the computation
over is very simple operation so you can
do multiplication so we are not done yet
because this error is getting bigger and
bigger so bootstrapping I will not
describe it I will skip it by is the is
a matter that is used to remove this
error and let me skip at the description
bootstrapping but let's see how it
provides one more met order to multiply
cipher texts now think of m1 and m2 has
been bits they are 0 in one but instead
of thinking of them as values modulo two
we think of them as value module a
larger modules 3 or 4 right now if
instead of multiplying + 1 and M 2 you
add a map you will get either 0 1 1 or 2
so you get something which still adds
enough information to tell what their
product is their product should be 1
only when the Sun is equal to 2 in
particular it can be computed by taking
the Sun dividing the Sun by 2 around in
the result either 2 0 or 2 1 so you can
perform multiplication by adding the two
cipher texts and then dividing the
result by 2 an operation that can be
performed essentially for free during
bootstrapping not for free at the same
cost as with no at this
not cost over bootstrapping and that
provides one more metadata multiply
ciphertexts okay so there are many more
fhe schemes that have been proposed in
the literature but i think that they can
be classified pretty much based on how
multiplication is performed and fit into
one of those four categories so let me
conclude with a brief summary I describe
the lattice basically tog Rafi Ahmet
order to encrypt messages which provides
both conjectured resistance against the
quantum attacks and also very simple net
order to adapt ciphertext together
amorphic Ali and SMS surprisingly this
also allows to compute the product of
two cipher texts and this leads to a
very fully homomorphic encryption which
supports the computation of arbitrary
functions on encrypted data and so this
still a very active research area with
many open problems but in terms of
improving efficiency of home Orphic
encryption and also security
specifically when you encrypt a key
under itself which is needed before
reduce traffic in okay so thank you for
your attention this concludes my talk
and is just a list of the papers that I
didn't mention explicitly during the
presentation vanilla I want to say first
of all thank you very much for a great
talk and completely very deeply
apologize for this press time and what
I'd like to propose is that there's
probably a lot of questions and people
would like to have some expansion on the
stuff that you skipped like the
multiplication methods especially three
and four I know that's true for me
so all right since we don't have time
for questions because apparently we're
gonna have this link kept from us due to
some I think it's understanding maybe I
can send a link out to we can find a way
to send a link out so that we can have
another 15 minutes to ask you questions
and so forth okay yeah yeah that's fine
I'll stay available and wait for a link
or so we can move the media to a
different person yeah so at this point
before the high tech person somebody
wants to ask
question let's open it for people either
panelist or any questions from the
audience
so I guess my question is the following
the last it's one way to compare these
two four methods that you describe for
multiplication and can you do a quick
comparison of which one should be used
when or which one clearly is better in
terms of efficiency yeah so of these
four methods the last one in some sense
it is the easier to use because it
allows you to compose the operations any
way you want because you're doing
bootstrapping all the times but
currently is still not the fastest one I
think it may become an attractive
solution in practice but it's not quite
there yet is the newest them now the
previous method the multiplication by
tensor India is that one that you know
the previous one which is the GSW method
so this table is used for implementing
the bootstrapping the creep the
bootstrapping procedure of the fourth
method so in some sense it is already
being used there they preview na so
these last two methods have the
advantage of being based on harness of
lattice problems within polynomial
factors so if you are concerned about
using the weakest possible assumptions
that's those two are the best choice the
first and second method in some sense
the second method is a more efficient
version of the first so the first that
doesn't seem interesting at this point
other possibly for just presentation
purposes and so the second method is the
one that is currently most efficient
when you have to perform many
computations which are also
parallelizable assuming you can make an
assumption that like these problems are
hard for super polynomial factors and
that's basically the bgb bfv
implemented using ring glasses for
efficiency that's a yeah so this is the
second method so by I think all four
methods are still interesting even now
as techniques for which we may found a
way an interesting way to use it for
example the third method is used inside
a bootstrapping procedure of the fourth
one and since the oldest methods are
using the same basic encryption function
there is even of even a possibility of
combining them together so rather than
just move into the latest from the
research perspective I think it's
interesting to still think of all these
possibilities okay wonderful so we do
have a link and it's just been sent to
all that in these so whoever once can
switch to that length to stay and we
also asked the newly more questions okay
okay you have it in your I think you
have it on the side and in the chat
because you are yes so I'll move there
so yeah thank you